good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast and happy
friday friday gotta get down on friday
everybody's looking forward to the
weekend weekend which really reminds me
i actually had a question for you
which seat can not take
that one that's your seat that's your
side thank you so much i know it's
confusing welcome back to the morning
toast everyone happy friday i hope
everyone has
has had an amazing week is having a
great kickoff to their friday and you
probably are if you're watching the
morning toast you definitely are if
you're watching the morning toast we're
wrapping up week one of florida week but
i think we're moving into week two i
know and like week two is going to be
crazy let me tell you why well first of
all
claudia's not going home this weekend no
no no i feel like i thought that you
probably would i thought you would be
tired of us i'm tired of this town like
have a plan but like the other night
like maybe last night ben like brought
up the fact that he like
you know like when are we going home and
i'm like what are you doing like shut up
he was talking about going home yeah i'm
like what it's not the time it's not the
time it's really not the time my
nibblings need you i have literally
nothing to do at home and i'm being so
[ __ ] productive here you are so um
but it's also going to be like a crazy
week next week let me tell you why
there is potential that we win the
lottery tonight so honestly if that who
knows if we'll actually be here on
monday if you want we might have jetted
out if you won the lottery would you
still do the toast
i was just having this conversation with
shapiro because we were talking about
like we all quit our jobs and i was like
no i actually like my job but i might do
it once a week okay yeah and like also
you like like the fame you know yeah
right so i would never step back from
the spotlight no like you do this for
the fame and the fortune and the art and
even if the fortune came like you still
want the fame but then you could just be
like a famous lottery winner right which
is like kind of tacky but i'm okay with
it
you could pivot the podcast to like how
i spend my earnings today right or you
could launch a new podcast at tnn like
how i'm spending my earnings yeah like i
keep bringing it up my lottery dream
house my lottery podcast yeah that would
be the inspiration because and honestly
my co-host needs to be like the tattooed
gay guy who hosts my lottery dream home
he's so funny and he's like so i'm out
of a job oh for you win the lottery and
i'm out of a job that's not gonna work
sorry i was like so busy making
everything about me i forgot you also
would be winning the lottery oh yeah i
would be right actually you didn't send
me the twenty dollars yet for the
tickets so
um you do venmo i take quick pay venmo
cash app zell i would
like some hacker is gonna like figure
out yeah
and then
you'll have to give up your house and
you just moved in i know with our new
premium video like you guys could see
also next week is going to be
so crazy because we just have like you
know so many things being delivered like
this set is just going to be constantly
changing it has been this week yeah i
don't want to over promise no no i just
think there might be a new fresh look on
monday there might be or tuesday
or hump day
which would be a really good day for
change yeah um so i actually had a list
of things where's my phone but also i
just want to say that not only is it
friday it is stride and i feel like
we're not appreciating the fact that
like florida toast means brass and
straws on the ones and twos every single
day it used to just be like a special
occasion i think it only ever happened
twice in new york whereas both boys on a
dry day and now it's every day is friday
and
it also happens to be friday which just
makes it so much better yeah you know
that's why it's friday right but would
you say it's friday if both the boys
weren't on tuesday no did i say it on
tuesday i don't remember you're always
like larping i can't keep driving no
it's friday is only when bryce and
streets are in the studio the stripes
brothers are here on a friday then it's
friday got it got it got it um pretty
simple to me extremely simple i had just
like a list of things i wanted to talk
about one was the lottery like just
warning people like if there's no show
on monday it's because we won
two
yesterday we dropped a vlog on our
patreon that was literally getting such
rave reviews when i was editing it i was
like is this too chaotic but people were
craving the chaotic energy maybe it's
because claire crowley has taken a step
back from public life that people are um
craving chaotic energy and basically
olivia jackie me and roldini all went on
an afternoon outing to publix where we
all had our very uh first pub sub
and we did a whole taste test it was
like a mukbang a vlog a
food review
and a family-friendly tv show all in one
and the reviews on the pub sub are
extremely mixed so if you're one of
those people who's like pub subs or your
personality you might be triggered and
you might weaponize that against us
result resulting in us having to
gaslight you and body shame
um so patreon.com morning toast we still
have one more episode dropping this
month and it's going to be family
friendly fun because all steams are well
i forgot
cut that out um because olivia's here
jackie's here shapiro's here why did i
say here ben's here theo's here bryce is
here rolled us here okay
though and you know what she misses us
too have you spoken to her no actually
because i said i spoke to her and i was
like do you like miss us do you care
you're having fomo yeah and she said
yes i can't watch your stories and
that's when you know
it's cutting her why doesn't she come
for the weekend or something she's like
so [ __ ] busy i know that like if she
was actually doing nothing this weekend
she would come that's so snatchless
she's just in that phase of her life
where like her summer weekends are like
fully planned out like trips to the cape
clam bakes you know et cetera it's hard
to get on her schedule maybe in the fall
it's so hard to get on counts of
schedule yeah and we didn't prepare um
also
while you're enjoying this if you're
looking for something to do afterwards
our episode of breaking bread that we
recorded live on wednesday is now
available on spotify for anyone to enjoy
and consume oh that's a funny one that
one's really funny and then
yesterday when we were talking about
glee on the podcast i actually facetimed
you yesterday to tell you this but then
i'm like you know let me save it for the
podcast okay we were talking about you
know quickly yesterday on the podcast as
we always do as we were talking about
you know how new directions really
wasn't
the best name for the group and i didn't
even realize even though maybe i did
that you know so many former glee cast
members are toasters and i got a message
actually a voice memo from jenna
ushkowitz who played tina and she was
like first of all love the toast getting
me through postpartum life and i'm like
yes queen
and fellow pp mama and she said like i
was dying listening to the conversation
because like they literally called it
new directions because it sounds like
nude erections
i saw that yesterday but i also saw that
like someone just said it sounds like
new direction so i wrote back i'm like
is that like a purposeful thing are you
[ __ ] with me or it's just like a
happening she was like no like that's
literally why but then i also saw a
comment that someone said that the
creators like his hometown glee club was
called new directions i saw that too but
i'm going to choose to believe jenna
ushkowitz a hundred percent i'm going to
choose to believe eyewitnesses right
right not comments
not comments
i trusted
if i trusted every comment i read i
would be big yikes all the
time the only worse than yikes is big
yikes big exactly emoji
claudia texted me yesterday morning just
big yikes
because that's like the evolution of
people starting to use the yikes it's
like a condescending term on the
internet has evolved into big yikes
being like the worst version of it and
can i just say ever since we kind of
like spoken about the stigma of yikes
like people have been messaging it to me
like as a joke obviously and it doesn't
like scare me any less like seeing yikes
in my message even if it's a hundred
percent like obviously referencing a
joke and this person is like a true
toaster i still get a pit i'm like oh my
god i'm literally being canceled yeah no
their comments on um
the picture of you dead there was a
really funny comment appropriating the
dead yikes and at first i was like
and then i laughed yeah but honestly
like part of me wishes we never brought
it up no i think we're taking the
scariness out of the words we're taking
the power out of the words and we're
we're taking our power back we are
taking our power back and maybe by
talking about how jokey all these big
bad words have become like we can
eventually give them their power back
and not abuse them 100
100
that's what we're trying to do here
just no small feat just trying to change
the world just trying to like
give the power back to language
and change how people speak you know i
like i'm actually really triggered by
like the word language
i love it i'm obsessed with languages
and the idea of languages and obviously
the tower of babel oh babel's today's
sponsor
should i do it now yeah you have to this
conversation about languages right now
is brought to you by babel and also i
have a really interesting story to share
about languages which is why i brought
it up okay
today's conversation about languages
coincidentally is brought to you by
babel for all your summer travels
whether you're going abroad or staying
domestic and you want to immerse
yourself in the culture now is the
perfect time to start babel babel is the
language learning app that sold more
than 10 million subscriptions and thanks
to babel's addictively fun and easy
bite-sized language lessons there's
still time to learn a new language
before you reach your destination so i
took babel in italian um before i went
to italy rome for my friend's wedding
and it's so helpful first of all because
you can get so lost if you're in a
country where you don't even speak like
the basic language it's also just like
you're putting yourself in a vulnerable
position like someone will see you and
be like you know she don't know what's
up yeah or if there's an emergency like
how do you write hospitals right so with
babel you only need 10 minutes to
complete a lesson so you can start
having real life conversations in a new
language in as little as three weeks
other language learning apps use ai for
their lesson plans but babel lessons
were created by over 150 language
experts so what you're saying is other
language learning apps could never no
what i'm saying is this is not like
other language learning apps that's what
i'm saying with babel you can choose
from 14 different languages including
spanish french italian and german
and you can start your new language
learning journey today with babel
there are so many ways to learn in
addition to lessons you get podcasts
games videos stories even live classes
and it comes with a 20-day money-back
guarantee so right now you can save up
to 60 off your subscription when you go
to babble
b-a-b-b-e-l dot com t-m-t as in the
morning toast that's babble.com tmt for
up to 60 off your subscription babble
language for life now what i was going
to say as to why i'm triggered by the
word language because um when i was a
freshman at nyu
you have to take like a certain amount
of class credits in certain schools like
arts and sciences like for like the
basic ones so you just choose random
classes that you think are going to be
easy that don't pertain to your major
and olivia was a senior at nyu and she
also had to um do like an arts and
science so we decided to take one
together and the class we could not have
chosen a worst class it was called
linguistics linguistics colon languages
of the world so i thought it was just
going to be like you know what do they
speak in brazil brazilian you know i'm
kidding i know it's portuguese
um so we thought it was gonna be so easy
we literally the i don't i can't even
tell you what it was about i had no idea
what was going on
literally the class wasn't even taught
in english like we were writing in
hieroglyphics like i was so confused and
i failed it's like the only class i've
ever failed and i didn't get the credits
and i think olivia not to like blow up
her spot got like a c which i was glad
to take the f because like if she
she was graduating she wouldn't have got
the credits if she got an f so i took it
for her yeah and there was another girl
in her class who had like a job lined up
at morgan stanley she was like a big um
stern school of business girly and
literally she failed and like couldn't
graduate it was the hardest class so
honestly like every time we do a read
for babble i'm triggered because i'm
just reminded of like the languages of
the world that i don't know and every
time we do a read for babel i am joyous
joyous because it reminds me of the
tower of gobble that biblical story and
i just think there are so many
metaphorical applications for the tower
of babel in everyday life that's so
funny you know what biblical story i
find like myself applying to everyday
life samson and delilah and like the
hair oh my god i mean how many
influencers go for a bob and cut off
their power right but
more often than not you go for a bob and
it like transform you into into a
sophisticated woman
women oh my god i'm one of those people
that's one of your biggest pet peeves
when people miss it's not because i
confused women and women it's because i
can't [ __ ] speak because i'm like i'm
not sure i have a clogged duck and i'm
oh
yeah like i had i was getting clogged up
once a week and then i went like a month
without one and it just came out i'm
sorry i know like after a long week i'm
gonna massage it no after a long week i
was looking forward to
you know a nice relaxing friday striding
but the clogged duct anyways that's why
i said women okay it's okay you're
literally entitled mama like soon i'm
gonna be telling you when i'm on my
period oh my god that's how
contradictory i've become now i've
gotten to a place where every time i see
an influencer posting about their period
like i will send it in our steam's chat
i need to know yeah i need to know
anyways um babel samson delilah yeah
most influencers when you go for or just
people in general i think going for a
bob is like a way to take you like just
to a new sophisticated new level every
place in your life but sometimes people
cut off their power a la samson
i'll assume
so that's like a biblical story that i
find like really um
like applies to everyday life like and
it's not only always about hair but like
everyone has a thing like samson had
that makes them who they are yeah and
then a person a delilah will come in and
take it from them yeah i always forget
about the delilah in that story she
literally cut his hair i thought it was
like yeah no when you think about it
yeah i just think about samson and his
hair she's like a jezebel
big time and you know what they say
about jezebel jezebel don't even stand a
chance we're literally such bible girls
bible girls and that's the cool thing
about that album it's extremely biblical
and like what album
kanye oh sorry i forgot we were talking
about music um
like when he thought the book of job was
a job and but now he can appreciate the
story of job i thought you were gonna
say which is what i'm gonna say and
that's the cool thing about like the
bible is that while we are jewish like
all of our christian catholic toasters
like know the story because like part of
it is the same book yeah so we're just
like bringing people together through
religion mm-hmm that's us
um so we've got a great show five
stories before we get into them though
we need to talk about something like
really major that's happening on your
couch
what pearls yeah i'm wearing pearls
claudia is wearing a string of pearls to
coordinate with the pearl buttons on her
cardigan who is she she's a suburban
mama oh my god i did not really she's
going to lunch with the ladies at the
club at the club and then they're going
to do like a little book club and have a
glass of chardonnay a crisp glass i
didn't realize you were like so taken
with my outfit every day you've shown up
to my house like right as i'm finishing
my makeup before i get dressed and like
you're coming in these looks and i'm
like ready to put on merch every day and
i'm like [ __ ] i have to get dressed well
let me say i have officially plowed my
way through libby austria's closet like
sweaters mine this is everything i'm
wearing today is mine i've like tried on
everything that i like and would fit me
and i feel like i'm pretty much at the
end of my rope now so i have to go to
into my own closet and i absolutely have
to go to the mall this weekend like to
get some clothing shopping um
and this is a cheater yeah i was telling
olivia like i've never until i tried
stuff on same i've never ordered from
princess paulie before have you
no but the snatcher is getting me close
so remy vader got me close because like
there was cute clothing that looked like
it would fit me so i ordered and i've
loved everything i purchased from there
and they their sizes run big and there's
just something about something running
big that makes me feel so like teeny
tiny you know
and i was telling olivia i'm like you
should order it's like reasonably priced
and
it's great so i really enjoy it and so i
got this sweater from there and i like
i'm not sure when the right time to
where it was and happen to have packed
my pearl necklace not the one ben gave
to me the one i bought myself um and
i've been watching too much drag race oh
my god drag race finale no no the winner
was announced wait
wait the winner was in london i know who
it is don't say it okay
wait how did i literally skip a spoiler
i saw it um when i was looking for
stories this morning it said the winner
was announced i actually clicked it to
see if i won but don't tell me if you
did the most annoying thing is like it's
paramount plus so i think the episodes
come out friday i'm so used to it being
on cable every friday night but i think
they drop it like midnight on thursday i
hate this is what i hate about the
streamers like kardashians there's no
catch up like people need a minute if
it's on at 9 00 pm like people can watch
it and then go to bed but if it comes
out midnight we're not teenagers who are
staying up like until one in the morning
to watch something oh my god [ __ ] i'm so
annoyed i really hope drinks monsoon one
i'm not looking at your face
um but i forget the point i was trying
to make before but thank you i like my
sweater too and i like your fanny finney
skins jacket thank you i just really
realized that it's reversible so now i'm
wearing it like the other way but i've
worn it the other way and i'm also
wearing skim's
slippers so i'm just like kim's girl i
will say i have worn like that material
windbreaker on the podcast and it's
really not a podcast friendly material
if you talk with your hands a lot okay
well since bruno is on my lap oh and my
hands are really cold it's okay bruno
you're doing so good and mommy loves you
so much
i wish there was a thuma i had today but
there's not damn there's going to be a
thuma ad in my house every single day
soon because snitch's bed is coming oh
good what were you going to say i forgot
about your jacket
it's reversible you were like well bruno
because we were talking about the
material it's not good for podcasts
no no bruno since he's on top of me like
maybe i won't move so much right he's
holding you down metaphorically and
emotionally and physically just like the
tower of babel keeps you humble and just
like delilah
also keeps you humble unfortunately
in an unfortunate way um so that's
really all the catching up i have to do
what about you i think that's it oh i've
been reading the book for the redheads a
flicker in the dark i'm like 66 of the
way through i like it
so good well i like it if you can
stomach it because it's extremely spooky
oh you know i like about missing girls
but it's so good and twisty and i think
i know what is the roundup i think i
know like it's a whodunit i think i do
know
but
i don't know this the writing is so good
it's like
it's so on point it might be one of the
best uh we've read so many good redheads
books but it's definitely the best
thriller we've read at the redheads i
can't let me tell you why i just had an
experience that i meant to mention on
the podcast i was reading one of my like
really cute rom comes when i told you
about the two girls who marry movie
stars and in one of the books like the
movie star's ex-husband ex-wife has like
a crazy stalker and the stalker breaks
into the house and it wasn't like a
particularly thrilling or like amazingly
written book but this particular scene
where like the man breaks into the house
was so real i was quaking even though it
was like a very light book
that night
i heard something in my sleep and i
flipped over and screamed and i was like
ben did you hear that i literally was
having like night terrors because of
this one scene in this romantic comedy
and it wasn't meant to be that scary so
i definitely can't read that book i'm
not good with stuff like that yeah no
last night i had multiple
anxiety-inducing dreams i wouldn't call
them nightmares because they weren't
like so crazy but extreme like i woke up
like oh my god pita patch
one of them involved theo
i i've already heard about the dream and
it's very upsetting and i wish to not
repeat it it was bad
yeah we're just glad to see theo here
today is all i can say he's literally
been such a good boy really enjoying the
florida life i'm so happy to hear that i
finished a whole book in one day
yesterday while finishing hotel
nantucket i was reading so fast
yesterday i read um
taylor jenkins read one true loves okay
really good everyone's like you're gonna
love it and i really did i think i gave
it five stars and i've been really
stingy about my five stars this year i
think i've only given like two yeah i
haven't given very many and i've only
read taylor jenkins reads like
historical fiction you know fake uh
famous people but yes evelyn hugo yeah
uh daisy jones you know malibu rising
but and i started one of hers that's
like about regular people and i couldn't
even finish it i really didn't like it
one true loves is like really cute but
it's also like it poses such an
interesting i can tell you the plot
because tell me it's it happens right in
the beginning so the main character
gets married love of her life yadda
yadda um
and he literally goes missing in a
helicopter crash and dies so she goes
through the grief she meets someone new
and like right before she's supposed to
get married to that someone knew he
turns up like he was never dead so then
she's like choosing between the two of
them and it's just like it's it's
interesting and everyone lands on a
different side like she chose right she
chose wrong i happen to agree with where
she chose did she make a choice is it
one of them it's not like i'm choosing
me no in the whole book you know she's
going to choose someone no she doesn't
choose me i would never enjoy it i've
never given about five stars where
someone chooses me that's such a cop-out
yeah no it's what i'm saying about
choices i
that you know what i was trying to say
do something like a [ __ ] choice
agreed she makes a choice and she
doesn't make you wait terribly long i
love it and you know what it's like
that's the thing about choices this is
what i was trying to say like even if
she chose the other person that she
didn't necessarily agree with like
she made her choice yeah and it's okay
you should read it it was really good
and short my favorite oh okay i have so
many books on my tbr which is a good
place to be because there was a time
when i there was nothing left for me to
read i felt like i read every book we've
all we've been there so i i'm happy to
be in this place
if you want to become a redhead it's
really the perfect time because this
book is not just like i think all the
girls are really gonna love it and now
we're at three for three on like an
amazing book streak and the book that
margot is choosing for next month you've
already read i think this is what she's
choosing but snitch snatcher gets so
unpredictable saturn doesn't choose it
like i'll be so mad it's a book that i'm
obsessed with it's like trendy right now
yeah right no it's the perfect thing for
her to choose it's a snitchy choice the
thing about snatcher though is she
doesn't want to be controlled and she
doesn't want to be predictable right and
so if she knows that i want her to pick
something like she's might swerve left
no she'll go out of her way not to
choose just because it's her choice and
at least she's making choices you know
that's so that's the thing about choices
but it is a book that i want to read and
having it be a redheads book i do read
it so
i think it's the perfect time to become
a redhead you guys it's like back to
school season true it's such a vibe to
like pick up a
great book with the redheads and then
have a podcast to listen to where we
make fun of it even though we loved it
100 that's what we do
you know what else we do the fast five
stories the fast fight stories that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning toast
today's episode is brought to you by
first leaf
it feels like you need a degree in
grapes to find great wine these days you
can shop by label i guess you can try to
remember what tannins are but shouldn't
it be easier and that's why first leaf
does the hard work for you they make it
simple to discover new wines you'll love
without the hit or miss first leaf
samples over 10 000 wines a year from
around the world and selects only the
finest bottles they take the time to
learn what you like and what you don't
and then they send you world-class wines
tailored to your taste so i've been a
first sleep girly for a while but i
happen to be staying at first leaf
number one customers
house this weekend this week this month
i don't know um and it's been such a
premium experience just knowing like
whatever wine you're gonna grab like is
premium it's pre-approved it's tailored
to your taste and i'm not one of those
like snobs who's like swishing it around
i just want it to taste good and i don't
want to pay a lot of money um and that's
literally the concept behind first leaf
also if you're not a happy if you're not
happy with the wine that you receive
they will literally just credit you for
another it's super simple it's really
risk-free and if you're into wine but
you don't really know like where to
start try firstly if you can sign up
today and get your first six bottles for
39.95 that's literally under 40 dollars
plus free shipping when you go to try
first leaf dot com slash toast that's
t-r-y
f-i-r-s-t l-e-a-f dot com slash toast to
get your first six bottles for 39.95
plus free shipping try firstleaf.com
toast today's episode is also brought to
you by zip recruiter we're so excited to
travel this summer but have you ever
thought about all the people that make a
vacation truly great you got the hotel
concierge the tour guide a server a chef
and you know that outstanding talent is
crucial for a successful business so if
you're hiring you can find talent for
roles like these and more at
ziprecruiter when you try it for free at
ziprecruiter.com toast so ziprecruiter
uses its powerful technology to find and
match the right candidates with your job
you can easily review these recommended
candidates and invite your top choices
to apply additionally zip recruiter has
a complete suite of tools that makes it
easy to filter review and rate your
candidates
four out of five employers who post
unzip recruiter get a quality candidate
within the first day it's a no wonder
zip recruiter is a number one rated
hiring site based on g2 satisfaction
ratings as of january 2022. so travel to
this easy to remember website
ziprecruiter.com
that's where you can try ziprecruiter
for free again that's ziprecruiter.com
t-o-a-s-t zip recruiter the smartest way
to hire
great okay our first story uh candace
cameron beret and jojo siwa saga
continues we also have been pronouncing
her name wrong it's candace kamen burr
i'll think about it i said
burr i just feel like i didn't get beret
out of nowhere because i would never
pronounce b-u-r-e beret do you think i'm
lying no i just think the instagram
comment that told you that no it's like
100 percent candace kamen bear no but
like i heard beret somewhere i'm gonna
i'll try and transition but we'll see
maybe you heard beret when you were like
sorting through michaela's collection of
hair clips and you're like oh what a
cute beret
brett anyways jojo
raise a hat
red is a clip sorry it's very confusing
jojo was stopped at the gas station
and asked about her recent feud with
candace jojo said that she didn't share
all of the details of the meeting after
confirming the actress did call her um
after their recent feud she said quote
we did speak on the phone she shared
that in her instagram video it was at
the after party that she didn't want to
take a picture with me and i was okay
with that the dance moms alum said but
then i turned around and when i looked
back she was taking pictures with other
kids siba said that's the part that made
her quote really really upset calling it
one of those memories that always just
stuck with her but when you're little
and somebody says something to you and
you just never forget it as long as you
live i think we've all had that moment
and i feel like that this was that
moment for me
okay
so
that is a real moment that you know it's
giving me and hillary duff honestly oh
yeah that is something else no but but
it sounds like you have that moment it's
not necessarily with a celebrity it's
just like an adult makes you feel a
certain type of way and it just sticks
with you and it's unfortunate that like
this was that moment for her and that
like she's digging her heels in now yeah
see the thing is is like i just need to
know more about like if someone says no
to taking a picture with you that's
they're allowed to do that for me why i
hold a grudge with the hillary duff is
she came over she was so [ __ ] rude
if i take a picture with you will you
stop staring at me
yes thank you um so like
turning someone down for a photo while
it's like embarrassing for you they're
completely entitled to do that okay even
if she turns around and takes pictures
with other kids and fans but
like
why do i have any reason to believe that
candace cam and beret would
intentionally like target an 11 year old
jojo siwa no i don't think it's like a
targeting so maybe she didn't want to
take pictures and then she got dragged
into something like oh my cousin's
daughter loves you like i don't know
i'm not like into this storyline at all
like unless jojo really explains like
if candace was actually rude it sounds
like she's holding a candle for
something and like she shouldn't have
put it she's allowed to like feel
however she wants to feel like feel
triggered or just happen to remember
this weird moment but to like talk about
it online and now like dig in even
further i'm like what are you doing yeah
also she's at the gas station filling up
her car and she's like videoed by
paparazzi and
so it makes me feel like she called them
to say this again right like how did
they know she was going to be at that
gas station right they're not just like
waiting at the gas station jojo see what
comes by in the middle of a feud right
it's not like it's outside craig's right
papa or lax where paparazzi just
happened to be but by the way even if
she went to craig's i would say the same
thing like she went to craig's to be
paparazzi to talk about this some more
you know i could see a world in which
she went to craigs and then there were
paparazzi and she was like [ __ ] it let
me just say it but like gas station is
definitely giving set up
unless there's like one gas station in
l.a that paparazzi hang out at and like
celebrities that's actually not a bad
idea like make it the go-to gas station
where if you're a celebrity you pull up
i would be getting my guests there every
day hoping someone would recognize me
and that's where paparazzi goes so it's
like a mutual unspoken
like situation yeah
but yes i didn't even think about the
fact that this is more than likely set
up
so she's making it seem like candace
cameron beret's like recount on
instagram was not entirely true
yeah except they're saying the same
thing i guess it was an after party not
a red carpet and i guess at a party she
would have more bandwidth to take a
picture versus on red carpet where she
really is working i don't know it's just
like it's while it is awkward it's not
the craziest rudest thing for a
celebrity to say no
to taking a picture with a fan i mean
it's not you know
kind but it's not warm yeah but it's not
like outwardly rude no some celebrities
are weird about that like
like have never said yes to anyone but
the thing is she was saying right
but i just don't think it was like a
targeted thing i think like those things
happen like you don't want to take
pictures then your agent comes over and
it's like oh well your manager's
daughter like is here for about mitzvah
like you know what i mean
like those things just happen yeah so
until i hear anything really damning on
candace cameron beret as it pertains to
jojo siwa i'm not with jojo on this one
i think maybe she needs to have a
cigarette and calm down
or maybe she's had too many cigarettes
and she's amped up she's yeah itching
for a fight i just want to say like when
we used to talk about jojo siwa chain
smoking in her bathtub it was like such
a farfetch'd concept
but the modern day jojo siwa is probably
smoking cigs in her back she's like a
badass she cut her hair yeah she doesn't
give a [ __ ] what anyone thinks clearly
so i agree i don't think it's so
far-fetched we were joking we were
larping when we said that jojo's about
chain smokes but now it's like maybe she
does yeah maybe she does what if she
just lights up a cigarette
that would be her prerogative
yeah i do like love the new jojo but i
do miss the ponytail i can't lie like it
was so iconic i do believe and i think
she's documented this on tick tock she's
like extreme hair scalp loss problems
from wearing a ponytail so tight since
she's been 11. well i saw a headline
today that she has a bald spot from
dance moms from the stress
yes she made a tick tock about it so
she was showing off her bald spot and
then it was like
throwback like the reason why and then
it was like a picture of her on dance
moms at 11 years old oh so
i don't know if she was referring to the
ponytail
or to dance moms being the reason
i would imagine it's the ponytail it was
so [ __ ] tight and she wore it well
into her teens yeah i mean it makes you
think about ari
yes
i mean that also makes me think of that
episode of kardashians where kim and
courtney went to an event and courtney
were like the craziest highest tightest
ponytail and then literally had a bald
spot in the middle of her head but from
one ponytail that's what she said
yeah
and she went to the doctor and got like
shots yeah wow wonder how that's doing
bald spots are tough because once you
get like get start treating them like it
literally takes a year for your hair
like to even know if it's working yeah
have you ever heard a bald spot
not like not like that i haven't no just
like i've had i've spots where it's like
sparse but not bald no no are you ready
for our next story
nicki minaj is coming out with a
documentary
the first trailer for her six part
documentary series called nikki is
coming soon and she's giving fans a
first look on thursday she released the
first trailer for her highly anticipated
project titled nikki sharing the two
minute clip on twitter she wrote coming
soon the hashtag nikki documentary you
didn't know you needed i love you so
much
the thing with nicki minaj is her
personal life is actually extremely well
i just want to say based on the
trailer and the quotes it's about her
rise like it's about becoming a famous
female rapper like you know failing the
the support that she did or didn't like
it's not current no it's not based on
what she just dropped honestly i don't
really feel like a documentary is a good
move for nicki minaj because at present
like her personal life is so twisted
like the man she i believe is married to
is a sex offender her brother is
i think
in jail for murder
so and
she doesn't speak on it because honestly
like it's not her who's done those
things but when you open yourself up to
a documentary
you really um
like there are things people expect you
to talk about it's like a book like you
can jail for rape oh sorry sorry i
missed raping an 11 year old her brother
her brother and then her husband is a
registered sex offender and i think he
might have done some prison time as well
so these are things people like know
about nicki minaj and she never
addresses them but you can't make a
documentary and like not
address the thing you know yeah that
would be like britney writing a book and
not talking about her conservatorship
it's the thing like everyone is that's
on the top of everyone's mind when you
open your your personal life up to a
documentary yeah well it's six parts so
perhaps you know the early parts are the
early years and the later parts are
what's current and maybe this is her
speaking on it maybe we'll see but she
has to her husband has been sentenced to
one year of house arrest because he
failed to register as a sex offender um
due to an attempted rape conviction from
1995
right
so
um
yeah like i think as long as she wasn't
opening herself up and like doing a
podcast or writing books or
documentaries she could get away with
not speaking on all this but now it's
like oh you're opening yourself up like
you
were curious what's going on
how do you feel about all this
question mark
did they say it's like a streaming is it
a youtube what is it or is it like dvd
it doesn't say got it it's just coming
out sooner than you think and
still like no specific date but that
there is a six part doc it's it feels
like one of those things that she's been
like filming herself for a very long
time yeah well i love a celebrity
documentary but i like more current
things like when people make a
documentary like i still haven't watched
jlo but like it's about half time or
that was lady gaga too um
i don't really love like this sounds
like more like an intro hollywood story
yeah the rise like if i'm gonna watch it
it's gonna be for someone i'm like head
over heels obsessed with like i would
watch out about like taylor swift or
i don't like i would watch a nicki
documentary if he was like what's going
on now her getting ready for her tour or
something you know yeah i feel that
but remember when they brought back each
hollywood story and then like never
brought it back
yeah because this is like hollywood
story concepts
you know like boy
yeah you know yeah it wasn't particular
people it was categories yeah it stunk
he is so weird to me like as a network
i'll never get over it like first of all
i think one of the biggest mistakes they
ever made was cancelling lady gang i
think if they gave them like a little
bit more time it would have been huge
two um
e news question mark each hollywood
story question mark
i don't know what they're trying to do
as a network i feel like for so long
they were trying to be like the pop
culture network they just like
squandered every good thing they had
yeah
i don't know what's going on there
and then the kardashians left and it's
just been
the literally like the last remaining
quality brand on a is daily pop
yeah the pops the pops and nyly pop yeah
are you ready for our next story why'd
you giggle like that because you said
that oh oh i thought that's there i
thought the story was funny it's cute
okay it's cute a california fruit stand
employee found a lost wallet and it
turned out to be william shatner's
while picking up some cherries at a
local fruit stand william shatner got
separated from his phone
so william for the star the owner made
getting it back to him a top priority so
the owner of the fruit stand when was on
break when william came through and when
he came back he found his belongings in
one of the bins and when he opened it up
he was surprised to see it was william
shatner the face of priceline yes so
they spoke to some local law enforcement
on getting it back to him they wound up
fedexing it and william got it back he
tweeted i would like to thank gary and
natalie of bnt farms for their extreme
honesty in returning my lost wallet they
are obviously good citizens i would also
like to thank officer mark terrasco and
sergeant ballard from the gilroy pd
my best bill
bill that's in the tweet yeah he calls
himself bill
um
i know we wouldn't put it in the tweet
but like
he like gave them a reward right like
you're a major celebrity like yeah
that's just what you do like
he seems like a normal humble human
being who wouldn't put that on a tweet
yes but you gave them like a bunch of
cash right like they literally gave you
back your entire life yeah i would hope
so like i've never i have lost wallets
it's never been returned to me and if
anybody ever actually returned it to me
i would literally kiss him on the mouth
and give him all the cash i had in my
house like yeah
you have like you have to
tell sugura that's a really funny in
this book i need to read it you need to
read it he has a really funny story in
his um book about finding a wall at one
time in a cabin like you know
fantasizing about when he found the
person and they would become like
lifelong friends and would be this thing
that bonded them forever and he could
not find the person like ever never
whatever and a few years go by
and he's like at a restaurant and the
waiter comes over and he's like he looks
familiar and it's the guy i think his
name is justin
that's crazy
freaking out and justin is just like so
about the whole thing and
it's so not like into it and it was like
such a letdown for tom okay i actually
have a similar story i was in a yellow
cab once and if you lose something in
the yellow cab in the city like you're
done it's never coming back uber you can
track it down and i have a bunch of
times and somebody left their cell phone
in the back seat i'm like i can hand it
to the driver or like just find out who
it is and like call them and
me you can come meet me
so it's this android and i take it home
i didn't tell the driver i'm like let me
just do a good deed
and i cannot open the phone first of all
i don't know how to use android it's
locked with a password there's literally
nothing i can do with this phone and
like it just ended up sitting in my
house for like years i think it's still
there oh my well that's weird because
usually you can't open someone's phone
but you wait for them to call the phone
to see where it is and then you pick up
and say hey john i tried your phone for
like a few days nothing came in nothing
came out then it died i was like i don't
have a charger like
it was just a good deed gone wrong yeah
and that's on trying to like i was
trying to put good karma out because i'm
always losing [ __ ] like oh maybe the
next time i lose my wallet somebody will
return it to me instead of stealing my
credit cards and of course there's
always the possibility of a meet cute
that's not what i was hoping for unless
it was like you know a really famous
talent agent with an android yeah no
with an android but i think in general
like people
say you found the wall it would be a
perfect book you found a wallet of a
handsome man you got you go to return it
yeah and you fall in love what a great
story that's the premise of an episode
of friends they find this like young
guys
um
cell phone and they like fight over who
gets to return it um and they're talking
to the young guy on the phone yeah
there's something exciting about like
finding someone's belongings and being
the one to return it and then a guy
shows up tom was so excited about justin
yeah and justin gave him nothing the guy
speaks bro shows up to return and he's
85 it turns out the young guy was his
assistant and he's like disgusting
looking but yeah yeah that is a crazy
story and how good is tom segura's
memory like remembering someone's id
oh he was obsessed with it yeah like he
spent so much time sounds like a makeup
story no no tom wouldn't like fiction
fiction honestly like that's a little
too convenient and there are crazy
things that happen but like that's a
little i think he says that in his book
that like he has some really crazy
stories that are like not to be believed
but they really happen to okay good
because i'm not believing them i think
let's just read the book liar are you
ready for our next story what number is
it four oh no i'm not
our fourth story is brought to you by
favor formerly known as the pill club if
you're thinking of switching birth
controls or maybe trying it for the
first time but you don't know where to
start favor provides personalized access
to care from the comfort of your home
and delivery to your door it comes in
discreet packaging on time every time so
the service that you know and love is
the pill club has rebranded we love a
rebrand and they're called favor now
favor provides digital care
prescriptions and products for your
well-being they combine medical and
pharmacy experience with an advanced
telehealth platform and their licensed
medical team puts your health first with
access to affordable birth control skin
care menstrual care sexual wellness
products and more with over four
thousand five star reviews favor carries
over 120 fta approved brands and ships
to all 50 states most brands of birth
control are free with insurance or
medicaid and otherwise prices start as
low as 6.99 per pack without insurance
fever delivers birth control to your
door for free and discreet packaging
along with fun self-care extras so right
now when you go to hey favor.com
toast favor is offering a 10 donation to
bedsider.org for the morning toast
listeners who become a patient your
donation will help low-income
individuals get access to birth control
through bedcider.org that's
h-e-y-f-a-v-o-r
dot com toast to get your first birth
control care package and donate to help
more women in need of affordable birth
control
hey favor.com toast and you have to use
that link if you want the donation to go
through great
our next story real houses of new york
sonya morgan puts her upper east side
townhouse back on the market for 8.75
million dollars she's the girl who cried
sale
sonia morgan is giving new york's lady
real estate market another go it's
perfect time
uh the star has relisted her five-story
upper east side town house for 8.75
million after attempting to sell the
property for nearly a decade
so new uh photos of the house have
emerged it looks really nice in these
pictures but having seen the ins and
outs on the show
this townhouse is kind of like a foreign
renovation requires a gut renault also
like the real estate photos that like
legit douglas element companies use like
are really edited they add like sparkles
and brighten them like
it looks good but like the photos are
definitely glorifying it a little bit
yeah she did fix it up as we saw on the
show and she wasn't living in it but
then she had to move back during kobe
because she didn't have a renter anymore
she's still not living in it but now it
is really and truly for sale but this is
just not the time
yeah new york city real estate is in the
tank but when it comes to like i
actually feel bad for sonia because i
think when she got this townhouse in the
divorce it was like a huge win for her
because at the end of the day a
townhouse on the upper east side is like
a valuable piece of real estate
but she hasn't been able to really do
much with it and it's so expensive to
maintain even just bare minimum like
making sure you know
leaks and she's not that but plus the
taxes on it right the maintenance so i
think it's become like a real burden for
her 100 no she's been wanting she's been
ready to part with it for a long time
now and like made peace emotionally
and she just can't make peace with it
physically and honestly like i don't
think like the notoriety of the the
townhouse when it comes to bravo and
like reality television has helped the
sell sale of the no because the buyer of
this house like doesn't want all of that
no if you're spending eight million
dollars on a townhouse on the upper east
side like you're extremely like elite
and like classy and elegant and like
that doesn't really you know those
aren't words i would
use to describe the real housewives of
new york city yeah
so i actually feel bad for her um
and like i hope someone buys it it would
have to be one of those things like
you know
like
people who like in the middle east
really rich people who just like buy
property in new york as like investments
or just like a place to put their money
they never lived there they never go
there and then they'll sell it in a few
years like i believe that's what happens
with joan rivers apartment like yeah
that's what happened at the plaza right
they sold all these um when they turned
it into condos and residences majority
of the people don't live there right
whatsoever it's just a place for them to
put their money to park some money right
so hopefully we can get like a rich
sultan or something for sonia and then
maybe they can start dating
yeah
a really good point yeah that's exactly
what she needs because it's really not
livable it has to be completely gutted
it's super dated and if you're spending
eight million dollars you want something
fresh yeah you want to live in the lap
of luxury right so it's a gut reno
and those types of investors who just
like buy properties don't ever live
there and so they don't really care what
it looks like
sonia and the sultan i would watch that
spin-off 100
100
oh also speaking of bravo we haven't
been able to speak about this because
the show got cancelled and i guess
nobody cares anymore but mike shoehead
from shaws of sunset was arrested on 14
counts of domestic violence oh my god i
know and i'm like really upset
jesus it's not like that
like shocking if you watch a show he's
like really toxic with women and
definitely has like anger issues so it's
like one plus one equals two um
but it would have been nice to have for
filming it would have been nice for one
plus one to equal sock in this situation
right i just like really there's not a
day goes by that i don't feel at least
once a day like
this is something she also sunset like
could have covered because it could have
solved could have addressed you know
it's such a good show
i'm sorry your cans look sick maybe when
we have toe studios you could reboot it
yeah that and the
new zealand girls and their farm
yeah and society season two would be on
toast studios gcb
um nashville
filthy rich remember that show remind me
kim cattrall she plays like the head of
course who could forget except that the
last few episodes like ruined the show
filthy rich the fx show starring kim
catrell as the leader of mega church was
amazing but its only i think issue was
that it really came out the same time as
righteous gemstones which is the hbo
bigger budget better you know cast
version of it and people love drag just
gemstones with john goodman i should
watch that yeah i started it me and ben
started we liked it but we just like
never continued it it just wasn't filthy
rich and it never will be no and filthy
rich was so good yeah are you ready for
our fifth and final story i really and
truly um some good and bad news to wrap
up a saga from this week which is
everyone hating instagram
instagram has nixed some tick-tock-like
features but it's still going hard on
reels is reals the tick-tockification of
instagram took a step back as the meta
owned social app said thursday it will
discontinue a beta test of a full screen
version of the feed and also promised to
reduce the number of recommended videos
photos and accounts that people see on
instagram i hope that means that
jackyard will no longer be seeing
accounts that exclusively have 47 likes
jessica's family reunion but make no
mistake instagram still putting its
shoulder into video continuing to
aggressively develop and promote reels
the tic tac style video feature that
lets users record and share videos of up
to 90 seconds
okay so like at least they back down a
little bit but they're just so like
stubborn and like
hell bent on
competing with tick tock that like
they're literally like losing the
respect of everyone yeah it's like it's
really turning it's that's what they did
with facebook everyone couldn't live and
breathe without facebook they made so
many changes kept like
they tried to be everything to everyone
but it's like
we can have multiple apps i have like
dozens of apps on my phone that i use
for different things i'm not looking for
one app to do it that's my phone my
phone does it all yeah that's so true no
they're like totalitarianists like they
have to be everything for everyone at
all times
like why can't happy with what you have
why can't we post our sickening pictures
on instagram and our sickening videos on
tick tock
i don't know it's so annoying and like
they get away with it like they copy ev
every app that's become popular on in
the world in terms of social media like
instagram copies that these copies
stories they copy everything and they
get away with it and like instagram
still remains like the center of the
social media universe and it's just
[ __ ] annoying no but i feel get away
with this too this time they've been
kind of stopped in their tracks yeah
they're gonna focus on reels but it's
really not happening the way that
they're not taking down tick tock and i
don't think that they will anytime soon
you can't like you literally can't but i
also think people's behavior is
different like you go to instagram to
see your friends and like specific
people that you socialize
but on tick tock you're really watching
strangers
and it's just different and that's fine
it's fine it's fine it's literally fine
they're just so annoying and the nature
in which they like like that's the thing
i think the most successful social media
apps um like really listen to what the
their users want like you know people on
tick tock like are always begging for
like different features and over time
like tick tock gives it to us like they
listen people wanted longer videos they
wanted more effects every time like um
a trend happens where people have to do
a certain thing with their camera tic
tac will create an effect that does it
for you like to help engage people and
make it easier for them like if you're
older and you don't know how to do
they're like
they'll make a filter for you so
that's part of the reason people love to
talk as a user you feel heard yeah
instagram is like oh what did you want
okay we'll give you the opposite
oh you wanted uh 10 minute videos sorry
we'll give you one minute like you're
always just doing the opposite yeah of
what people want and ignoring them and
it's so [ __ ] annoying
like remember how long it took them to
get filters that didn't make everyone
look like rats
yeah people used to film on snapchat
with like the dog ears and like the
smoothing filters save it and then
upload it to instagram like get with the
program yeah get the [ __ ]
program [ __ ]
you know who listens the streis brothers
and they've been so good today for
stride and those are the past five
stories and you definitely needed to
know every single one of them yeah but
if you're feeling rdh that the content
for this week is ending there's so much
more so much first of all patreon
there's a new episode up for patrons who
are already you know caught up new
episode us at publix but if you're not a
patron yet and you join today like you
have over 200 episodes waiting for you
and there are some
gems i mean we literally had two gems
this week we dropped a couple days ago a
vlog in this exact room getting our
studio together all hands on deck zach
was here zach was here ben was here
jackie was here strice was here i was
here bryce was here and we did like a
documentary style very you know the
office inspired video of putting
together the studio and it's literally
one of the funniest things you'll ever
see in your life
if we do say to ourselves so check it
out and then when you're done with all
of those 200 episodes head over to
spotify where our show breaking bread
new episode just dropped it's hysterical
it's really just become yes we talk
about pop culture but it's just become a
place where like it's a face time for us
where other people can weigh in no and
it's just become
literally like the moronic language
we've created here at the morning toast
and like
the people who understand the language
speaking that language yeah you know
yeah it's an inner circle thing yeah but
you all would understand because you're
part of the inner circle so there's
patreon there's breaking bread and then
we're gonna be back next week with more
shows so we hope this has been a great
first week we want to thank everyone for
being patient might i add like
now that we have our new sickening bugle
chairs
the outpouring of love for the couch
like i wait i like to the couch really
where were you when everyone was
dragging us to filth no nobody wants to
stand up for what's right when the time
matters now it's all in the past
everyone wants to say they were on the
right side you know we loved the couch
but please we heard the crickets i don't
want to hear that you loved the couch
honestly like i don't want to [ __ ]
hear it i'm triggered and you're
weaponizing my couch against me and so
i'm going to gaslight you in return
um
but thanks for being patient monday
tuesday was tough with the audio video
we got to a great place i feel really
good about it and we're going to keep
evolving keeping queens and thank you to
everyone who has been on this journey
with us honestly reading the comments on
everything we post on instagram this
week has been one of the highlights of
my life people are so [ __ ] funny like
me and jackie keep screenshotting
people's comments and sending them to
each other because you guys are so
[ __ ] funny yeah like i like them when
they find them funny but i just need to
make sure claudia saw it too of course
and by the way i've literally seen
everything like you don't even have to
send them to me that's so you still
should yeah i just want you to know like
what sticks out and like what you're
enjoying yes of course yes
girls who enjoy
so that's our
show oh and one more thing i wanted to
thank everyone who made gmail um youtube
accounts yesterday who got their mother
and brother to subscribe we got over a
thousand subscribers yesterday and while
it's good it's not good enough no i
really like i know it could happen
no offense like some of you are being
lazy
yeah we don't know how many people
listen to the show every day it's a lot
no this could happen in an instant if
ever we're talking to the podcaster
listen if you're listening right now to
the show i am talking to you yeah you
know you know you think i'm talking to
the other person yeah i'm talking to you
get on your gmail
go to youtube.com go to the morning
toast and just hit subscribe it's that
simple it's you
no no not i'm not saying to the abstract
you and you're thinking like i don't
need to do it there's so many other
people who listen like they'll do it no
[ __ ] you
yeah get your [ __ ] ass up and
subscribe to our youtube channel okay
we need to be in the three-digit club
like it's like embarrassing yeah 90k oh
my god you know what i think after what
we have brewing next week i know
brewing
people will feel inspired
to take up the mantle for us i don't
disagree
not in the slightest doesn't mean that
you shouldn't do it already today yeah
that's not like a pass like no no no
so thank you so much for listening to
the morning toast the millennial morning
show where we deliver the past five
stories that you need to know every
monday through friday on youtube so if
you're watching this on youtube please
feel free to subscribe or if you're
listening as a podcast feel please feel
free to subscribe we're also available
as a podcast anywhere podcast can be
found so that's spotify itunes stitcher
public radio i have radio cast box all
the places so wherever you listen to
podcasts find us the morning toast and
don't forget to leave a five star review
about how beautiful stunning and smart
we are hope you guys have an incred
weekend enjoy the weekend be safe have
fun
we love you in crayon weekend you guys
nothing less goodbye